citizens of the reject Nation Ron joxie
is back and we're ready to test our
might with Paul W S Anderson's original
Modern Combat did not leave you hanging
Roxy are you excited
[Music]
yeah that's right yeah R.I.P my
headphones let's do this thing I know
that you were in the arcades as a kid
throwing down mad coins on this yeah
listen I feel like I'm a big Mortal
Kombat fan but also I don't know if
that's true that's good that's perfect
because today we're gonna find out but
only if you leave a like on this video
as well as subscribe hit the
notification Bell check out the world
girls and also hey guys I just want to
say a big old thank you to the team over
at prepper for chopping down these
highlights because it's hard work and we
appreciate them for doing it also if you
want the entire the complete Mortal
Kombat experience alongside us see
everything that doesn't make these
reaction highlights come on over to
patreon.com the real reject sync up with
your own copy and join us for several
other movies and shows as well it's a
real blast Roxy yeah are you ready
that's not a line in the movie I'm not
watching it's okay I got you get over
here
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God we're just getting right to it
it's like wow all right okay oh man why
wasn't I in a theater for this I don't
know why weren't you
nobody's mad at that never that's like
the most iconic theme song of all time
oh
no
let him go man this guy's very different
from Ip Man that kid's a kid right he's
a young person
oh so you broke his back okay not cool
you can't be the good guy in the story
right no he's the hero this is the save
the cat moment your brother's soul is
mine
[Music]
oh Liu Kang
my man
the Western Union brother Dead return
home grandfather Jackson
yeah I'm gonna name you every chance I
get Jax I'm Sonia blade you're because
Sonya Blade I'm so Sonja blade
oh fatality she's here
right on time
oh yeah I love punctuality in a woman I
do too Mr Shang sung
not just in a woman and a person though
but yeah only in women dudes can be as
late as they want She'll follow you into
hell just make sure she's on there Sonia
blade must be at the turn
Mighty Man Sonia should share a cabin
have our own little Honeymoon Cruise
so much
he has values
oh no yeah yeah I get that eye acting in
there twitch those lids
the cool guy who is that playing Sonya
Blade I'm not sure
where's Kano where is he
asking Australian she looks like Cadet
Kelly
oh yeah Miami Vice Johnny caves that's
what I said I don't know I see palm
trees I think L.A or Miami L.A
you're a lot better at this than me I
mean I'd say it's not a competition but
it's Mortal Kombat
stands Let's Dance
well I wanted this to be sweet dreams
are made of these so it sounded like we
were getting into
what do you think the odds are that
we're inside
or is this a real fight I hadn't thought
about it till you said it but why did he
pull up and say let's dance in real life
yeah
[Music]
this is where you fall down
you knew
hey mister you're in my chair
oh no
hi Johnny you're one of the best martial
artists in the world
and I can help you prove it the
All-Valley tournament the tournament
it's held once a generation the best
fighters in the world are invited Cobra
Kai there's a boat leaves Pier 40.
Hong Kong tomorrow
oh the dragon
oh no no
you didn't see that one coming ah he's
fighting dirty
it feels like they're using different
kinds of cameras I know it's like they
had different film stocks for every
different shoot day or something but I
mean I don't know it does give it a
cinematic quality no it's working it's
just interesting it's like every place
is a different movie this is where we
found this spot you follow it in your
footsteps preparing for the tournament
grandfather it wasn't enough you filled
my head with that nonsense how can you a
wise man believe this well you're all
blaming it and we all got money on it he
is like maybe the best head of hair I've
ever seen in my entire life I know man I
wish I could get those feathers going
also a lot of smoke shows in this I want
to represent the order of light at the
tournament for what reason
the man who killed my brother will be
there I guess that's a good reason we're
fighting for the fate of the world
that's why you left the temple and ran
away
isn't it oh
who we got the great tournament was too
much responsibility but vengeance
yes that's so much simpler Lord Raiden
okay this isn't your god of thunder and
lightning he's just a beggar he's just a
white guy no a white savior
um of course yeah
righteous
Palpatine eyes if you are raided why did
you let Chan die why didn't you protect
him why didn't you
I know you are but what am I I'm rubber
you are glue what would be your weapon
of choice ooh I want to learn how to use
one of the like a like a blade on a
chain sick I'm pretty good with the bow
style in real life but I feel like that
would be super cool or nunchucks because
they never get respect on screen except
for in like John Wick 4 and Bruce Lee
movies you want me to carry your luggage
I pay money you carry the bags
I got it
yeah buddy
oh both of them didn't look good in that
exchange it's okay
oh my God
what is that I feel like we're at
Disneyland right now
or whatever the show they do
Hold On
Come to Papa he looks like a Hemsworth
that's right kaino Hemsworth the Lost
Hemsworth that's good thanks it's a
dead-on Kano Hemsworth impression hey
Sonia
I wonder if they choose chose to do so
much ADR because of the tradition of
like Martial Arts Cinema or maybe it's
just a thing that happened or they had a
bad bad audio day every day
it's an honor to finally meet you Sonia
At Your Service oh I'm looking for a
murderer but it is my boat and if you'd
like a tour I'd love to give it to you
myself it'll be 28 dollars just doing
her job when I want backup
a radio fort it really enunciates every
word yeah when I want to back up I'll
radio for it
and Scorpion damn
move aside
oh look at that and that's how he got
his name
[Music]
okay
looks more like Toucan Sam
follow your nose
that was a weird series of shots
we'll let them have it
enough damn that is expressly forbidden
before the tournament won't happen again
I promise you until we reach the island
Where You Have No Dominion my dominions
are well known to me sorcerer stop
talking about my Dominion you've been
chosen Sonia
Chosen One what you're about to face is
vastly more important than your ego oh
your enemy or your quest for Revenge the
focus he was talking to each of them
individually defend the realm of Earth
in a tournament called Mortal Kombat The
Forsaken land called out world ruled by
any mortal now he seeks a new world to
conquer an enslave yes went to the realm
of Earth the empress demon sorcerer
Shang Tsung and his Warriors have to win
10 straight victories in Mortal Kombat
the f19 oh no this will be the 10th
Sonia a handful of people on a leaky
boat Are Gonna Save the World
like those odds what about the others
they're all great Fighters but I have
looked into their souls oh and yours one
of you three will decide the outcome of
the tournament spoilers
rebellions will depend upon you
because comedy I guess so if you
challenge chang song now you will lose
your life and your soul he is going to
pay for my brother's death
oh look it has begun look the eagles fly
on the Wind to Mordor Wowie
there's Harry
[Applause]
okay you've done a good job identifying
every character though for people who
don't know Mortal Kombat at all you get
a good sense so far it's like if you
used to play as a refresher if you've
never played before you know definitely
who's the game character yeah wow man
this face planted right in the water
let's go
not Johnny is they cast him to be just
like an LA actor guy but like I'm like I
really believe this guy's a like a
warrior yeah I know I know like I'm sure
he'll get his chance to shine but I
always think you can walk to the top of
the steps I'm like I feel like you
really prioritize the actor part more
than like the actual martial artist part
well I've never seen him work since this
ah of course she's our most dangerous
adversary one so carefully reptile
keep her away from these humans
oh
no dude
I felt that these agents were not happy
that their actors were not able to have
their faces you know I know
plenty
the sounds are so great too
oh no oh no oh yeah
poor guy
okay
Flawless victory
yes
words I have seldom heard in this life
knows where
knows what she's wondering right man
when she sets her mind on something it's
not her mind you're admiring
good point so Johnny's here for his
career yeah if he wins the tournament
people will take him seriously as a
martial artist like his is the oh
zagoro I want to get to the bottom of
this are you out of your mind fast
the minds of Moria TDK Trilogy starts
now that's Kano
volcano where was the other guy yeah is
it any freezer this guy right
really have a turkey leg right now
disgusting what I want to know if this
Shang sunglies so great how come he's
got such a crummy looking boat
slaves souls he learned the Black Arts
from the emperor himself oh my where's
the emperor you're some kind of royalty
too right I am general of the armies of
outwork and Prince of subterranean
potato
something like underground yeah exactly
I've come to warn you that gong Laos
descending is competing in the
tournament I saw this new Kang in the
hall heel pose no problem he looked like
an idiot princess Katana is 10 000 years
old and the rightful heir to the throne
of outworld but she must not be allowed
to join with the forces from the realm
of Earth especially you can they're very
good hiders yeah and these guys are
great at giving out exposition
it's very dank down here is it drippy
moist it is drippy moist there's like a
leaky tap in the background oh
gex invisible kicks
oh pepper spray yeah you got Jurassic
parked
[Music]
it's a long time since we've had a fight
come on let's go
it's like burned into my subconscious
[Music]
more DJs to play this at clubs and then
maybe I'd go I know right you just need
to be clubbing with like 8th graders
it's like the best song
did they put a bowling pin sound in
there
nicely done
it's a good pose too absolutely
brilliant
an accent so why don't you show me what
you plan to do about them it's an Ever
evolving accent all right the accent
itself has a character Arc uh
no I don't think so
what is the little chuckle
just gonna punctuate everything I say
now with
tomorrow the Tournament begins
be prepared there are some cool sets and
like
[Music]
yeah I agree it's like it makes it so
much more jarring when the other ones
are kind it's kind of all working for me
though it's like
[Applause]
this is a very exciting moment for me I
bet look at these two I'm super in
psyching each other out
it's not mental combat though
mental combat
do you remember a lot of these locations
in the game I probably don't have like
that good of a yeah like oh I'm gonna
recognize every level like yeah I'm sure
this is similar to a level and I've
probably seen it but
[Applause]
bad oh
so cool if you can do that you can
really do anything your soul is mine yep
it's not a nice thing to do to somebody
I mean that very true Shang Tsung is not
a nice mentality fatality
[Music]
oh no who do we got it seems like
there's like so many parodies I know
it's perfect chest hair a perfect smile
on your partner though
oh no yeah what is Jack's not coming
back yeah study this
what song is this
this isn't the Mortal Kombat song this
is an interesting preparing
we had a knife
okay you know I mean half of them have
magic I don't think there are any sort
of weapon rules at all no no just she
she only has her decent fight I think
they don't care oh
spit on oh
yes choke them out oh give me a break
okay
oh
damn what what where was he just go
where is this
this is happening or is this sanction in
combat
get over here yes
parts of that visual effect look alright
but
oh
shaving away at that tree bark just what
is this part of the Mortal Kombat I mean
I think they're just throwing in fights
World Combat but that's like I can't
tell if this is part of it this is a
really cool setting now I think they're
walking around and they found this
location they're like
this tree bleeds
[Music]
I was gonna say this seems like an
attempt oh damn maybe it's like Shang
Tsung trying to take them out so that
they don't get to fight
[Music]
all right
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
okay but your career does need you to
keep your face
no money maker comes back with a cool
scar though so the winner of this fight
then what I'm not sure I still feel like
this is just an attempt to like take
Johnny off the board without him
actually being in Mortal Kombat but
really make sure we can see those milky
eyes
oh
sweet
this is so just so evil dead right now
that's on my list of things I haven't
seen what
whoa
[Music]
wow I mean I'm conflicted because I
guess they just killed scorpion Bros
that was kind of cool it's kind of
badass yeah yeah I'm curious how that
plays the rest of the movie it's a cool
fight
oh
[Music]
if you won't fight with all of your
heart there is no hope why do you care
if I win or lose I
know a shadow there to win your next
match use the element which brings Life
water
that's enough you disappoint me not very
wise
so for the next fight like that was that
clear as to like what the formal because
like structures
that's what three official fights and
then one side quest was that on an
official fight I guess I mean Shang
Tsung was there so I just I'm just gonna
assume that his officials somehow
right to business so is this one
sanctioned
[Music]
oh no
the element that's just she said it
what
oh in case we didn't get it at that
point nah man this guy's a master
what on Earth
it's okay buddy you got this
get
yes Ryan all right he is you know
they're working with the limitations of
this massive puppet
yeah
[Music]
it's only so out you can get yeah get
out
[Applause]
right that's what I like to hear
quite a climactic finishing move
bunk the Royal bunk
[Music]
raising him up is an offering
noise mine oh why didn't he take the
princess's soul I don't know I mean
she's still on the table right but that
was a fight whoa
despair is the most dangerous fear of
all I know this and so does shanksong he
can appear into your soul he he can be
into your soul come on it sounded like
I just want to know what that would feel
like somebody pee into my soul please
internet do not do your thing I guess
does that goes sterile I miss it better
than someone in your soul I
feel like I've had people on my
soul you go up against him he'll kill
you if I don't then he'll finish us off
one at a time you're making this all
sound really simple and it isn't yeah it
is because I can't let what happened to
Art happen to you oh oh he likes her Yep
they're the two attractive white
protagonists
it was predestined challenging Gore away
I'm not the one who's gonna die in
return I reserve the right to challenge
the winner myself in a place designated
by me they're bad terms and conditions
he brought it back
oh
what
he just punched him in the nuts
sorry this movie has to know it's it's
funny it's a comedy right it has to know
yes get it in the super wide
oh
this is where you fall down you know
what happens with toad when it gets
struck by lightning
[Applause]
oh princess or no wait that's Sonya
Blade all right either way no Sony no
it's the love of his life Sonia of
course they're romance I challenge
you were a coward sorcerer extend and
fight we had a deal remember I'm simply
changing the place
okay
is there an audience this time or no
audience wow
no you can't watch it's one of those no
watch places she has to accept the
challenge oh there can be no final
combat I have nothing further to teach
you looking you have learned all the
rules all the disliking now is the will
you sure you don't want to go with us in
our world if you look hard enough you
will find another guy
still gotta fight lizard
Luke Cage they are Luke Cage oh my God
what a Duo power man who needs Luke Cage
when you have Luke Cage Heroes for hire
right here
we should head for that Tower Shang
Tsung would have taken Sonia there wow
so she doesn't have to accept the fight
but she doesn't know she doesn't have to
accept the fight so they gotta get there
to tell her that I guess so for a very
climactic end what are you doing boom
what size is he supposed to be
I guess these things are alive did it
just feed it now it comes back to life
or oh
resurrected uh that's not what he meant
to do right is it one of them or is it
like a third one I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
where is Johnny is this outside waiting
around
yes
get him
[Music]
like this seems like a a little bit
unnecessary considering he's already
dead and then you strangled the gotta
get more pair UPS going two steps
forward
five steps back
[Music]
okay it's worth it for that we're not
seeing his feet move but we did hear it
and it sounded bomb
oh my bugs
nutritious slimy and satisfying
[Music]
squash that mean old lizard Hakuna
Matata what a wonderful phrase my father
was a rightful ruler of that world and
the emperor entered the realm killed my
parents and adopted me to lay claim to
the throne it's our responsibility in
the Black Tower you will face three
challenges you must face your enemy you
must face yourself
and you must face your worst fear and
then you will answer these riddles three
what on Earth they took the time to
tease her hair Slave Leia that's what's
happening
you don't fight the realm of Earth will
forfeit the tournament and its portals
will open to our great my friends will
come
they're already here oh we already came
that was unbelievable yeah that's the
best moment of the whole movie yeah I am
Liu Kang descendant of Kung Lao I
challenge you to Mortal Kombat do you
accept
[Music]
nice dress
bizarre such weird Chemistry Between all
these people
yes let's do this one more time
[Music]
that is pretty cool shot from above
come on
[Music]
yes Gaines
no
no you make me bleed my own blood nobody
makes
me sound source of all Shang Tsung's
power The Souls of a thousand dead
Warriors a didgeridoo
hey uh that was a pretty cool effect
is your enemy five henchmen
it feels like unfair what are the rules
like are there any rules These Are the
souls I know the rules are probably not
the the first order of business but like
are there any parameters to any of these
battles no no
it's more clear of the game can you wipe
your chin bro
[Music]
but half these guys are like
recognizable stunt actors
damn
that dude I can see into your soul okay
you will pee until you die
see your Schwartz is as big as mine face
yourself you can look into my soul but
you don't own it you haven't peed on it
yet that is how you take ownership like
a dog face me
oh
I knew it hello
you fall for it you just saw him do it
chin
[Music]
right he didn't send me to help you
you're not really cheap remember when
our parents died and you promised that
you would always take care of me uh-huh
now it's my turn to take care of you
brother by killing you in Mortal Kombat
come with me
want to die
forgive you for letting me die why is he
entertaining
no idea it wasn't my fault Chan chose
his own path every man is responsible
for his own destiny Samsung killed my
brother
oh my
[Laughter]
careful you got all the spikes down
there now
it looks like little Christmas trees
yeah or a bunch of little scorpions
under there just pushing their Palm
knives up to the floor the two of them
seem to be the two best fighters so I
like watching them fight
they are easily my two favorite
characters I think
let him go Freddy Krueger where do they
go when they escape him get out into the
ozone
is that what Global boiling is yeah it's
just all the soul energy let out of
Shanks songs
save your
save you dizzy for the week he does not
know how to spit
don't pity him
[Music]
so close boy you're so close take a hike
to this bike
[Music]
there you go a little lightning out
there damn
whoa
is that everybody's soul is getting
released I guess so
now it's the haunted mansion out to
poster guys
I said Poltergeist it's all good oh
ghost stuff I knew you'd come
okay
oh buddies one day sweet we will be
reunited but until then my spirit will
always be with you oh
very sweet moment
so long Thackery Binks
[Applause]
ah it's like a Shakespearean romance
humans are so unpredictable this is the
end of being girls I've got to tell you
something you guys did great this is so
weird
what is it
the emperor oh no
oh whoa
I don't think so
let's go
let's go Paul Anderson
I gotta see that girl's name oh boy
oh boy that was a lot that was a lot
how do you feel
it's immediate first thoughts podcast
listen once I decided it was a comedy I
had a blast sure but like I If I had
seen this in theaters when it came out
and hadn't talked to anybody I think I
would have been like a rather confused
yes I think five so well also that what
are your immediate thoughts yeah I mean
I can absolutely see why and how this is
garnered a cult following yeah total
it's Cult Love so that that is how it is
Christopher Lambert that was Raiden's
name I I always I always hear about his
performance in this movie you know like
Christopher Lambert in Mortal Kombat is
always like one of those meme
performances that gets brought up oh
interesting that was him
uh uh yeah I'd be like this is I don't
have like the greatest lexicon like I
haven't played every single Mortal
Kombat game and that was you know like
those kinds of games especially when I
was young and growing up were the kinds
of things I would have to get at like a
friend's house or in an arcade oh cool
the the uh ADI guys did uh Goro as well
they are uh
uh effects folks oh here we go here we
go I already saw Sonya Blake Bridgette
Wilson which I I I must have seen her in
something because that name doesn't even
ring a bell but definitely I feel like
I've seen her I've seen a few of these
people I want to look up what else
they've done yeah since then but yeah
like I don't have the best you know
overall lexicon to sit here and be like
well in the game lore and stuff like
that but um but yeah like this was very
fun but disjointed and yeah disjointed
is a good word for it because definitely
yeah and given the meme status that this
movie possesses in popular culture it is
kind of a funny one to go back and look
at it and two uh you know at the time of
filming this um I think this will go up
before it but we did a we did a
different reaction to the Street Fighter
movie
and that one has like sort of a more mad
cap tone throughout whereas this like
really kind of dips in and out of like
okay here's just kind of like a still
quiet scene of people talking about
stuff and then like randomly a fight
will break out and then that fight will
just randomly transition with no
transition into a different like Paul WS
Anderson has made so many movies and
granted this is early on in his career
but like this does feel like like it was
assembled by like a really enterprising
film student or something like that yeah
definitely act like a through line that
was cohesive and everything was
um contributing to it you know which is
totally fine because it was fun but yeah
some of the rules like that you and I
kept talking it's like wait what I left
this with very little concept of the
actual like world and rules of Mortal
Kombat outworld this whole Mystic you
know it's like a whole mystical ritual
that they've got going on yeah if they
win 10 times they can come destroy the
Earth and yet the the fighting which is
so much of the movie so much of the time
did just feel like of just a bunch of
fight scenes this really did feel like
they had a bunch of fight scenes and
they're like I don't know we gotta put
these in an order now uh let's get a
bunch of scene scenes and let's just
kind of put them here and there
throughout but not between every fight
and to have that it's such a weird
structure you're gonna be so annoyed
with me at home and I get it but like as
lover of Love shipper of ships then to
like not have all of a sudden you guys
are in love
see that's the thing is as often as I am
like give me a cool love story you know
like this kind of earn it you can't just
like say it and then also there was no
Makey Audi at the end there's two
couples and I'm like wait what well
that's the thing is is this this is a
movie I certainly would not come into
expecting any kind of romance and I'm
fine with that like especially in a
Mortal Kombat scenario I'm like I don't
need it here if they want to do it I'm
always welcoming but in this case it is
it it feels so much like a like a like a
pitch meeting episode where it's just
like they're in love now why because
they're both attractive and they're two
of the main characters like it's what
about the other two as well Lou and the
princess uh Katana and Luke Kang like
yeah like at the end they were walking
together they seem chummy you guys have
more of like uh you know Destiny slash
you know uh Heritage kind of thing going
on so you guys are together and uh you
guys are are white you guys are Browner
and you guys are whiter so we gotta push
together feels like it feels like
somebody decided in editing that that
was supposed to happen and then they
just kind of maneuvered the footage yeah
and like I if anybody's gonna like be
couples it's gonna be me but I was just
like what yeah like I don't know I'd
rather it if earlier on just like I'd
rather uh Johnny grabbed her and kissed
her and her been like it what no or
something just some kind of like yeah
anything I don't know anything to
establish or to build that up it does
feel just like a regular old Hollywood
thing to do and two because like Shang
Tsung and Kano like everybody's also
being like creepy and oogling Sonia as
well
so then you're like well why is that
starting a princess is super hot too and
then like at the end with the like I
knew it was all gonna happen just like
I'm telling you that was the Mean Girls
yeah and Raiden like is such a again
like I'm not like the gatekeeper of of
you know authenticity to the Mortal
Kombat lore but I'm like I don't know
what the choice was for this because
he's got I I love movies like this too
that have so much ADR because inevitably
you'll have like these kind of types of
performances arise uh and one of the
bingo card for me is uh when you have
like a voiceover that like doesn't seem
at all like the actors watching the
performance while they're giving the
voice over yeah and like all of Raiden's
lines felt kind of like that to me it
felt like it was like an extra
microphone on him that was weird it was
like because he's always talking kind of
down here and then like no matter what
energy level the scene calls for he's
always tucking like this strange
accident hey
[Music]
it's just yeah it has again it has that
sort of little kiddish storytelling
quality where it's just like and then we
go here and then this happens and then
we go here he looks like Carrie always a
little bit
yeah do you think let me ask you a
question that you're not gonna like but
I'm asking anyway
do you think it's possible that this was
a bad movie
uh I think it's possible see funny
enough this one I enjoyed yeah I enjoyed
it too I'm I I'm not saying did you or
did you not enjoy it is it possible this
is just not a good movie I enjoyed this
I think this certainly is or I see why
this has it's called status yeah uh it
this is not a very good movie okay in a
way that like I'm actually a little bit
surprised by uh and and maybe it's just
because like yeah what like watching
Street Fighter and I'm not gonna spend
much time comparing them but Street
Fighter is a similarly kind of wacky
Bonkers adaptation of a fighting video
game same concept just slightly
different Aesthetics but that movie
maintains like a cranked up to 10 energy
all the way throughout so like the fun
spirit is always there and you're like
even if this wasn't intended to be fun I
think like everyone was having fun
whereas this I can't tell what the
motivations were half the time and it
really feels like it's weird because
Paul W S Anderson has made so many video
game movies and he seems to care and yet
every single time I see I haven't even
seen that many but like whenever I've
seen him attempt it it's always like
did you did you actually play that like
did you did you just like see someone
playing this and go oh I can make a
script off of that and then just take
what you remembered and come up with
this movie yeah like because yeah like
it's got the characters that you might
recognize certainly at least a couple so
we we did set up we were like okay so
Sonia Blade's partner was killed by Kano
yeah so that's why she's here yeah and
then Lou's brother was killed so that's
why he's here yeah and then Johnny wants
to be a bigger action star so that's why
he he wants to be taken seriously
seriously okay so we at least like the
and then they were all super different
from each other so that worked still a
little confused on the princess like why
why she hasn't been killed like she
seems to Super not be with the the she
seems to be with our people right like
yeah but she doesn't seem to have as
like as much power to move around and
use her you know ancient so that was
interesting and then um why is what uh
white-haired dude's name again Raven
Raiden Raiden Raven Raiden might as well
be what is Raiden's
motivation uh you know he's the
protector of Earth Realms so he just
wants to help us win so that he can keep
protecting right okay okay
yeah yeah I mean there I think that this
had the ability to have a stronger story
that's cool Flawless victory
was fun at least it was fun I think it
could have had a stronger story it was
definitely fun it was fun I think there
are moments where it gets a little bit
stiff and there are moments where and
and two like there is a lot of action
and I and I don't think the action is
I mean you know obviously there are
better examples of quality action in
cinema
um but for what this kind of movie is
you expect a certain amount of action
that's what you want that's what you're
here for they delivered that and I think
a lot of the fights are pretty cool
pretty neat I do feel like this is
another movie where I'm like I wish they
put maybe just a little bit more care
into accentuating the choreography and
like you could tell what's going on you
could see the fights there's some decent
action in here I think and it's fun to
see the characters Collide and see uh
sets that resemble sets from the game
um but at the same time I'm like man do
some more long takes and let us really
drink in the choreography in the back
and forth and stuff like that that's
another thing this movie doesn't really
have they don't really have any
fatalities whatsoever which is like a
big part of the games like those you
know those moments where it's like
here's a really gruesome finishing move
yeah they just kind of say it but
there's no actual finishing moves that's
interesting yeah this is just an odd
thing so it's like and a lot of the
deaths and things there are moments
there are a couple yeah but just not
that variety is the spice of life yeah
and I mean you know that's that's one
thing the more recent remake did hone in
on is okay at least when they're doing
some kind of finish him moment they're
do have like a big puncture would have
kind of very striking move that they do
but anyway for what this was in in the
90s do are you surprised to not have had
any like
a-listers we're looking right now on
this Wiki and it says Cameron Diaz was
initially cast as Sonya Blade it kind of
feels more around the lines that you
would think that there would be in the
90s at this time for Mortal Kombat movie
I mean yeah and again it's funny because
I think you know it's like a you look at
a movie like Street Fighter and that has
like Jean-Claude Van Damme Jean-Claude
Van Damme and like a bunch of other
recognizable people whereas here you
pretty much I mean you have uh
Christopher Lambert and you have uh you
know Carrie hiroyuki tagawa as uh tagawa
as um Chang Tsung like they're to me the
most recognizable Bridget Wilson but
yeah it doesn't seem like they had the
full range of both like recognizable
actors but also like recognizable
martial artists and stuff like that too
you have to click on Bridget Wilson it's
driving me insane she must be the star
of a TV show or something else that I've
seen she apparently did her own stunts
for this okay well she's in the Last
Action Hero and Billy Madison
and uh some other things okay so I've
seen her in a bunch of stuff yeah I know
what you've been on Last Summer
but yeah like okay Frasier it certainly
has like I liked a lot of the sets and
stuff like that and a lot of like the
crazy you know temples and skeletons and
monster creatures and stuff like that uh
there's a lot of really do you like Goro
he's he's neat he's neat for what the
movie is uh I think you know again doing
the whole like punch him in the nuts
thing is like very that was hysterical
silly 90s thing to do I was stoked with
that moment because that made me think
that the movie knows that it's funny
like it was like yeah we're gonna have
him punch him in the nuts it's certainly
yeah gave it a sense of of innate
cheekiness which I appreciate yeah uh I
guess yeah and they're like I thought
the effect and the choice to make that a
practical puppet and animatronic and
performer hybrid effect was a cool idea
and I certainly really enjoyed watching
it there are a lot of I mean I gotta
hand it to uh you're saying the whole
thing was a puppet
yeah I mean I'm sure it seems like
there's somebody in there yeah I mean I
thought you maybe have one set of arms
that's that's you know right maybe
there's a person in the puppet suit
that's what it looks like and then
they're probably wearing a helmet that
someone's radio controlling because you
know I mean uh I got to go to ADI uh the
Alec Gillis and and uh and Woodruff and
Gillis the two guys uh credited there
they have you know like an effects house
and stuff like that and they've done
like a lot of really cool animatronics
and puppeteering and things like that
and various other movies like The
Predator stuff and but yeah like that I
thought was a cool effect I'm aware it's
an effect uh I think it might have
played better if there wasn't so much
questionable CG around as well because
you know it's funny because you'll watch
stuff from this era that has certain
elements of CG and lately I've been
seeing things where I'm like oh looks
surprisingly good for the time at least
um and in this you know like most of the
CG looks like you're watching it on like
a PlayStation one you know like it it
kind of looks okay when uh the little
night you know the the mouthy knife bits
come out of Scorpion's hands but even
that's kind of wonky looking the lizard
effect is certainly like your it you
know reminded me of gex or something
like that some kind of old video game
would you watch this again
uh with people probably I don't think I
would have as much fun just watching it
alone and putting it on but you know
it's got that cozy 90s aesthetic it's
got some again Vibes these like archaic
ancient temples and stuff like that like
I like The Vibes of this I think it's
fun but uh you know as a Mortal Kombat
movie it could be giving you more stuff
I guess
um you know it was fun it was decent I
didn't I didn't quite immediately just
like love this the way I think you might
if you were there at the time but I
certainly appreciated the experience I
certainly uh had fun getting acquainted
with the memes that this movie has
birthed and has you know become in and
of itself
um there are characters I would have
like you know it would have been cool to
see Molina who's got like the big uh
crazy like um demon mouth that opens up
and you know she's a kind of violent and
cool character and uh and you know I
don't know if they were if she was even
invented at the time for Mortal Kombat 3
I think is the movie they were trying to
Hawk for this but uh either way I mean
yeah you got your requisites like you
got your Sub-Zero and your Scorpion and
angoro obviously uh uh and then yeah
Johnny Cage Let's see we got the whole
list Liu Kang Sean Connery was offered
the role of uh Raiden which also would
have been like a funny like Highlander
thing that would have been cool um yeah
Liu Kang Johnny Cage Shang Tsung Sonya
Blade Katana Kano Scorpion Sub-Zero
reptile uh and we had Jax although he
just dies off screen which is a bummer
um I thought it was interesting how much
that director did look like Steven
Spielberg the one that was doing cage
yeah he scrolled while I was reading
sorry about that yeah you're trying to
make me look stupid like you better
remember Sandy Helberg as the Director
of cage is saying and initially they're
saying it was supposed to be Steven
Spielberg which have been so cool but he
looked so much like Spielberg on the
thing you know what I'm talking about
yeah no no it's always like oh damn that
must be a reference yeah and then it was
supposed to be him that's interesting
God this is an interesting movie okay on
Rotten Tomatoes there's a 45 yeah
I mean you know yeah I think that's that
kind of sums it up they say despite an
effectively otherworldly atmosphere
inappropriately cheesy visuals Mortal
Kombat suffers from its poorly
constructed plot laughable dialogue and
subpar acting and it is one of those
movies where
it's not going so hard and just so mad
cap that that it just like gives way to
just a barrage of fun like you know
there are there are some flat moments in
here where you're like oh yeah I'm kind
of watching a a not great movie that is
very fun to behold yeah you know I would
assume audiences would have liked this
more than critics which it seems like
they did yeah sure and again like I get
what's lovable about this um it's just
yeah it's just not as like cranked up to
11 in terms of like memeable uh it's not
like silly at all times you know you
know but there are there are a couple I
haven't seen all these memes that you're
talking about I gotta go look I just
like this movie just has that status you
know it's like it's looked at as one of
like you know people still hold this up
as one of the better video game
adaptations and for its time certainly I
think it is taking the subject matter
with some seriousness subject matter
with some seriousness it's at least
attempting to translate what the thing
is even if it's doing it in a very sort
of add yeah kind of Half Baked sort of
away like it feels very kind of off the
cuff a lot of this stuff
um it feels like they showed up a lot of
the time just to the set and we're just
like I don't know I guess we'll just
shoot over here and now we've got a lot
of trees in the forest it feels like
they made up on the set they were like
we got a boat set today I guess we're
doing this what are we having at our
disposal yeah totally uh well yeah yeah
it's still it's still a very very
enjoyable time uh I think I like Street
Fighter a little better than this but I
I still enjoyed this quite a bit you've
got a journey ahead of you and then you
can come back and tell me which one you
liked better okay
um but okay I will any final thoughts
before we hit the road you know what no
no nothing else to say about good old
Mortal Kombat you're not excited for
Mortal Kombat Annihilation 1997. that's
the thing yes same actor sequel I
imagine I don't know but actually you
never know honestly the way these movies
work yeah I would watch it I would
happily I would happily watch it I do
feel that because I didn't I was not
miserable sitting here I was excited
sitting here yeah it's just like huh
yeah
yeah yeah
it does it's a very hot kind of thing
and there's a lot of like random plot
threads that you're like wait hold on
what
yeah just I just I could have used yeah
just like a little more structure to
what it even means to be at Mortal
Kombat because once they show up it's
just kind of a hodgepodge of like I
guess there's fighting kind of
everywhere and like how is this
different than Earth and it's like
um there's like a bunch of people who
showed up to compete here we never see
again you know like it's so it's such a
strange movie but hey it was a good song
he took their souls and he eventually
gave them back though we won Earth is
safe we didn't give them back makes you
happy this is a true story this is the
story of how we were saved
um interesting well guys why don't you
save us in the comments by leaving your
favorites uh part about this movie
favorite characters something you wanted
more of leave us your thoughts whatever
they might be and hey before we get out
of here let's do a patreon
Brian Perry I can just imagine hearing
that name on the start screen of a
Mortal Kombat type game Brian and then I
was gonna make you do it right on
battery Brian Brian Perry that's good
that's good Brian Perry wins we said on
um the other video on the Street Fighter
video we picked a patron who's gonna
have to go up in a street fight but now
Mortal Kombat against another Patron so
Brian Perry you are going to have to
unlock your supernatural abilities as
well as your destiny figure out what
your finishing moves are what style of
fighter you might be we'll even have
some advice like what would yours look
like you know we gotta give them some
things to choose from what should Brian
Perry be okay Brian Perry
um
oh
it's like a sideways what was that what
do you what were you imagining well
imagine fists or is that like a weapon
of some kind no those are my
Chop Chop what are what do you what is
the job try to give Brian a weapon and I
don't know I better give him a finishing
move okay so you're gonna do the chop
chop yeah yeah cause then they and then
their body Slinky there you go and then
their body like yes apart and uh and
bleeds you know in all different
directions yeah if you can hunch
somebody in the dick as a move then you
can do the job job
that'll be it that'll be the one to
punch you you can chop chop and then
finish with with the nut punch finish
him and that's how you will take down
pandemic Jones when we finally make you
fight to the death in Mortal Kombat but
for right now stay pledged that's the
easiest way to keep Earth realm safe and
uh hey we'll catch you on the next one
love you buddy peace out